j'ai eu des fous rires j'ai eu à la des
petits loupés j'ai mon fou et qui kaka
c'est au milieu d'une recette de cuisine
mais c'est les aléas du direct et puis
bah ça fait je crois que ça fait plus
rire et puis c'est des bons souvenirs
[Musique]
ouais
je compte sur vous pour participer
pendant l'histoire
[Musique]
on a mis une semaine à réfléchir au
projet à faire appel à youtube heures
qui nous a fait là qui nous a fait
jingle une copine qui nous a fait des
l'habillage le réalisateur de mon mari
qui a fait la réalisation en direct
et puis moi j'ai construit toute la
trame j'ai récupéré du matériel j'ai
construit le décor est mis toutes mes
idées sur papier et puis et puis voilà
c'était parti quoi
[Musique]
bonjour à tous petits et grands et
bienvenue dans cette première émission
de la maîtresse part en live au début
non ça n'a pas été facile on a fait
quelques essais mon mari mabri faire un
petit peu j'ai commencé à être vraiment
à l'aise au bout de quatre cinq
émissions
[Musique]
trouble notable labeur
en europe
[Musique]
c'est un atelier sur les pays tels
avantages de youtube ça dépasse les
frontières
j'en avais qui venait du canada
d'afrique de
nouvelle zélande
[Musique]
j'ai vraiment vécu comme une parenthèse
et comme une occasion une occasion en or
mais j'avais j'avais envie de retrouver
le contact avec les élèves par le bruit
c'est sûr j'ai du mal à me réadapter au
début l'émission m'a permis je pense là
en prenant du recul sur cette année de
m'améliorer dans la pratique que ce soit
au niveau
aisance au niveau théâtralité
[Musique]
suis jamais considéré comme une star et
les médias ont beaucoup monté ça en
épingle en dix ans la star la maîtresse
devenu star non je suis resté une instit
voilà à faire mon métier
ce que je garde de tout ça beaucoup de
reconnaissance de parents et ça fait ça
fait vraiment du bien parce que la
reconnaissance on on la voit souvent en
fin d'année où c'est un peu la fête des
maîtresses à la fête un peu commerciale
est donc là cette reconnaissance de fin
d'année en fait je l' ai eu tout au long
de l'émission
[Musique]
e